[موسيقى]
الفرق بين هذا العيد وعيد الماضي انه عيد
الماضي كان له بهجه اكثر له سرور له فرحته
له ما اعطائه اما هذا العيد فقدنا عالم
كتير بالزلزال يعني اليوم كل بيت في شهيد
وفي جريح وفي مصاب وفي مفقود يعني هذا
العيد مر علينا هو عيد رسول الله بس عمومه
الباقي الاعياد موهومه العيد الماضي مامه
العيد اليوم
نجتمع اكلاتنا عند الامنه عند ابونا نعيد
له نطلع اخوتنا على اخواتنا نروح نحن صلاه
العيد نرجع من صلاه العيد ترجع تلتم
الاسره كلياتها على المحبه والتسامح نحن
ببلده النزوح يعني بالنزوح يعني كل واحد
في ديري اللي عم يوصلنا في بعضنا هو موقع
التواصل الاجتماعي مثل الجوال يعني اليوم
اقرب اخلاقلك او اهلك او غيره عم بيكون في
مسافه بعد وقلت الواسطه يعني القليل عندك
اللي تنقلك من معطره ماكس ساكن لعند اهلك
او لعند خرايبينك يعني اليوم كل واحد
[موسيقى]